my name is Rick Eberhardt I'm the studio
manager for the MIT game lab I've been
with the labs since 2007 2006 so since
we um we formed a long long time ago
before I worked at the lab most of my
background has been doing information
technology for academic Institute's so
colleges and universities I always had
an interest in games I actually had a
cultural studies degree in an college my
for my undergrad so coming to the lab
working at the lab for that first year
as a system administrator really opened
my eyes to all the different things
games can do and the different
potentials games have but also made me
realize I can actually start making
these kinds of things on my own too so
since I've started working at the lab
I've taken on more duties related to
project management things that I'd uh
I'd already done a lot in IT managing
people managing projects I teach this
creating video games course um and for
the most part in the course I'm
interested in teaching the product
management techniques but also the soft
skills and the social skills I'm an
introvert I have a really hard time
having conversations with people and
I've had to in my in my years of my in
my profession figure out ways to get to
not let that be a restriction and
actually use that to my advantage when
I'm talking with teams on and I find a
really successful actually in game
development I don't know if it'd be
successful elsewhere but there's a lot
of other like-minded people like me and
gay involvement so it's it's it's good
to have for me to be able to use those
skills in that in that setting the other
advantage I have at the game lab is I
get to do research I get to help with
research on various different types of
projects so my personal research
interests tend to be towards closer to
what the this class is talking about
this meaningful decision making I've
done some some research in using board
games to teach decision-making I'm in
particular like economic concepts like
opportunity cost
I'm interested in social experiences and
games and cooperative gameplay past
games I've worked on have been about all
sorts of different things though
anything from tools to help game
developers make 3d characters animate
faster basically due to speed up the
workflow process to gamespot depression
and games about other serious topics I
really like working with researchers I
like working with clients and I like
making games
what am I playing now so I am playing
this game called grid land made by the
sand LOL pre-made a previous game called
a dark room it's kind of difficult to
describe it's basically match 3 game
where you're like the jeweled you're
matching gems but there's a small supply
chain mechanic going on in the
background where as i as i have the gems
combined i can upgrade my weapons and i
can upgrade my armor and then when night
comes so I'm matching gems in the day
time to upgrade things and when night
comes I'm matching gems to summon
enemies and to kill enemies so this grid
line game has a night daytime at a
nighttime view of the game and what I
find really interesting about it is that
all my decisions I make in the day are
going to have some kind of influence of
my nighttime decisions so as I make my
daytime experience easier I'm actually
making my night time experience harder
so it's just a really interesting little
challenge that the designers put for me
to try to solve
so outside of the class the kinds of
games i'm making our non-digital
prototypes so card games in particular
that are experimenting with things like
the a tech tree and a a 4x style game so
if you've played a game like
civilization or Starcraft even they'll
have these tech expansion trees so I'm
playing around with designing a game
that's largely just the tech tree I'm
doing that with a co-worker here drew
I've also got a game I've been working
on off and on for the past couple years
about managing cities about three
players trying to manage a city their
counsel people I'm trying to convince
the mayor about what decisions they
should the mayor should make to the city
but unfortunately the mayor is just the
role of a six-sided die so you can try
to convince him or her what you want but
it really doesn't matter because mayor's
got its own agenda so then trying to
solve the problems with the city while
also trying to solve your own personal
try to basically get political gain
while solving the the city's problems
there's a lot of different co-op
experiences out there from anything from
over the table like cooperative board
games to couch style co-op in front of
the TV I think trying to think my
favorite co-op experience is definitely
not pandemic which I think we're talking
about in class today I have a heart you
have a hard time deciding what my
favorite co-op experiences because so
often one of the challenges with co-op
games is somebody takes control and
somebody says what the whole everybody
on the team is going to do and
unfortunately I'm one of those people if
I know the game I'll start being bossy
and I'll take over and what I'd love to
see more co-op games do is put in
mechanics that prevent me from being a
jerk or enable other people to override
my jerkiness somehow
so the thing i look forward to most in
this class every year is the play test
sessions especially when it's the first
time the team has brought the game into
the class and they're putting it in
front of new users which we only have a
couple up a couple opportunities for
each project for that to happen in class
after that everyone in the classroom
seen the game before so they're not
giving the same kind of feedback and
what I really like about it is when the
games come in and they just they just
don't work there they're broken horribly
not when it's the technical problems not
when it's the code crashing or if the
broken build that's actually really sad
my hate to see that but when it's a
design issue when they thought it was
going to do this one thing and they see
that the game doing this other thing or
they see the players doing this other
thing it's that it's at that point that
the students understand that okay people
are do people things humans are human
right they you can't always predict
everything that they're going to do but
also that the systems that they created
are actually incredibly complex so the
things that they need to do to fix those
systems are going to be reducing
mechanics removing things from the game
making it a little bit more simple so
they can predict a little bit better
about what's going on but then on the
flip side of that though there's
sometimes when you see something happen
in a game and you just get this emergent
gameplay that it's just it's better than
what they were going for they didn't
they didn't realize they wanted it when
they see it in action they're like oh
this is actually really great what can
we do when we're finishing this game to
really capitalize on on this mechanic or
this system that we just didn't even
realize was there
I really like systems my the outside of
the class the thing I think this might
be the thing that I actually I like I
always had in some capacity but I really
coming to MIT working at MIT it's much
more part of my life is seeing the
systems or that surround us and the
systems of history I've always had an
interesting history and a little bit of
an interest in anthropology but reading
Charles man's books about 1490 1491 and
1493 what happened during the Columbian
Exchange when all of these different
ideas and products and agricultural
things swapped places from east to west
from China to the America is to Europe
there's some really interesting systems
and a lot of the problems that we're
facing the day are the direct result of
that of that English that that big
expansion of ideas and trading of ideas
so I've always been interested in those
kind of things on and I'm watching the
wire I really like the wire and just
seeing the systems that are involved in
city planning in police work in
education in all these civics the the
civic institutions that we just take for
granted every day yes the wires are very
critical and very pessimistic view of it
but it is a great expression of just how
all of these problems are connected and
some of the problems that we're facing
right now is just we can't see the
connections and I hope that at least
with with games with playing games with
making games people can better
understand how those how those systems
work
for for the future of games games as
expressions of systems games as ways of
exploring the world around us we've
always thousands of years ago we used
games as ways to communicate with each
other to have rituals with each other to
to better connect with each other and I
think we can do that with just games in
general much as video games but all
sorts of different kinds of games so
seeing those kind of seeing that come
back on to both what people are talking
about when they talk about games in
mainstream other than just this thing
that's done for fun it's actually this
thing that's very important to human
daily life and we've been doing it for
years it's just it looks different now
but it's still based on a lot of the
same things